reckless driving in the east valley
leads to a homicide investigation
this happened around 7 30 this morning
on hollywood boulevard near sahara
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with the latest on the case
kristen sasha the investigation involves
a bicyclist as well as a minivan driver
and
passenger police say the crime started
when a group of cars
started racing south on hollywood police
say a man between 18 and 22 years old
decided to have
half of his body outside the front
passenger van
window a couple walking this morning
tells investigators
the driver of the van came close to them
on the sidewalk and
the passenger attempted to hit them he
missed but continued down the road and
then purposely hit a woman riding her
bicycle with his hand
police say the bicyclist in her 50's
fell and died
when she hit the ground the passenger
tumbled out of the van and traveled
about 150 feet until his head
hit a streetlight which killed him
police say this is an extremely unique
situation
and uncalled for you have a woman who
was out riding her bicycle and
you know they pull up next to her and
strike her causing her to die
is an absolute senseless act again
there's no
no reason behind her that i could tell
you is why it occurred other than
complete stupidity police are searching
for surveillance video and talking to
witnesses
the van speed during this crime remains
unknown right now
but police need your help finding the
driver of the
minivan he's described as hispanic
between 18
and 22 years old anyone with information
should call metro police or crime
stoppers
that number is at the bottom of your
screen it is 702-385-5555